and did and did you hear Cyril gone he
did an interview in French he's like
yeah the thing about me is you know I
really don't train until I get to fight
that's all
excuse me yeah and I thought for sure
you get like hate on people like man
that's how big of a freak he is I'm like
yeah yeah you can't wrestle or grapple
though yeah I thought he was just
working on his grappling wrestling
outside of fighting like not during Camp
nope I can't have size enough I was like
oh I'll bet my house on Jon Jones now
you don't grapple and wrestle outside of
camp
hey hey Monsieur you're
straight up dude it's gonna be a tough
go for him in the office you got out
grappled by Francis and he had one leg
Daddy